these cows give organic milk for most of
their lives they've gone out to graze
and their feet contains no chemical
additives the rekha family makes 50
cents a liter on the milk before they
went to organic they ran up losses for
months until last week we were supplying
conventionally farmed milk and we got 25
cents a liter in practice that meant we
had to find 10 to 20 thousand euros a
month - more or less cover costs and
that's simply not sustainable because
after all hitmen in Georgia many farmers
blame the big discount supermarket
chains for their low incomes they sell
farm produce at rock-bottom prices a
liter of milk here costs only 59 cents
agricultural sector analysts say there's
too much conventionally farmed milk on
the market volumes have to be reduced
dramatically I'd say they'd have to fall
30% before it even becomes noticeable
and you could start getting a better
price for the milk this farm outlet in
Brandenburg only sells organic products
shopping here can be twice as expensive
as in a discount supermarket a liter of
milk or 250 grams of butter costs well
over a euro anyone buying here is
consciously turning their back on the
cheap milk and meat products on
discounters shelves it shouldn't become
a massive business generally speaking
we're ready and willing to pay a
sensible price for a sensible product
organically reared pork often costs over
10 euros a kilogram in organic
supermarkets it accounts from year one
point five percent of the market in
Germany just like milk there's also a
glut of conventionally farmed pork
butcher Bruno Epke says the market has
become saturated because Russia is no
longer buying meat and exports to Asia
are faltering
when you look at production costs around
the world in Germany in Europe or in
Canada and South America you see that
European production costs are so high
that it's hard to compete with the low
production costs in other parts of the
world in antonovitch to Coquelin
the transparent dairy in Mincha hufa
south of berlin processes the becca
family's milk it's one of the biggest
organic dairies in germany the crackers
are glad they converted to organic
they're convinced the organic milk
market is set to grow and will provide
them with a sustainable income